[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
ah
um
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Music]
you know what that is don't you
it's a dreamer orb jam-packed with pure
creative energy straight from the
imagisphere
but you'll need more of them if you're
going to make it up there
you are here to stop vex aren't you
yes yes yes but first you need to know
about the dark foul energy of nightmares
we call the uproar
vex is planning to fill the whole of
craft world with it for now he's using
it to block the way to the top of the
mountain so no one can interrupt him
luckily there is one thing that can
counter that nasty stuff
and you're holding it
the energy of pure wonder and creativity
inside it will dispel vex's barriers
wherever you find them
so seek out these orbs they are the key
to your journey the key to your destiny
the key to dogs is where you know you
get the idea
next time we meet i'll reveal great
cosmic secrets maybe tell you a bit
about myself like my name which is
scarlet by the way and more importantly
the truth about your very existence
[Music]
[Applause]
you wish to change clothes buy fabulous
new outfits
you have come to the right place for it
spend collectables to purchase
stupendous styles then create incredible
new looks in your wardrobe where you
will find all your fantastical fashions
oh and yeah i give you some free
collectibles just for you
to spend here at zum zooms
[Music]
so
you are always welcome so buy something
get out and then you can come back
what a business model
oh
[Music]
so
want some of that
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
great
so
oh
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
first
hey
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
um
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
uh
okay
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
right
so
[Music]
bye
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
oh
get ready for a cornucopia of
collectables
[Music]
pretty quickly it is almost up
how about spending those collectibles at
zoom zooms you deserve a treat and i
deserve to be paid
[Music]
hello
welcome to zum-zum's feast of fashion
we are at the top of the craft world so
pick a top outfit